[Musique]
comme chaque jour manon se prépare à
donner un cours de fitness mais un cours
sans public et sans public ou presque le
cours est retransmis en direct sur les
réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
on a eu le premier confinement et on le
faisait déjà la maison puis après à la
salle donc en fait c'est juste une
continuité c'est vrai qu'on préférait
les avoir avec nous mais on s'est adapté
et ça fait toujours plaisir de la
retrouver tous les jours pour transpirer
ensemble et communiquer et partager
condamné à rester fermé les salles de
sport vous de trouver des solutions pour
conserver leurs adhérents et maintenir
le lien avec eux dans ce club
l'idée des cours en live s'est très vite
imposé on a beaucoup d'adhérents qui
nous soutiennent et on a décidé de ne
pas les laisser tomber non plus mais
évidemment ça compense pas je pense que
tous les adhérents ont hâte de revenir
et sincèrement on a hâte qu'ils
reviennent aussi parce qu'un club 100
adhérents ben c'est triste
donc non ça compensera jamais et
heureusement parce que c'est aussi notre
avenir se joue la bande
le club propose 40 courts en live par
semaine et les sportifs répondent
présents depuis la fermeture de leur
salle arnaud et sophie suivent un cours
presque chaque soir dans leur salon
[Musique]
c'est un petit peu d'organisation soient
faut déplacer enroulé un tapis faut
faire un petit peu de place et puis et
puis on arrive à s'organiser avec un
ordinateur et dansante
donc ça me convient je me vois pas
rentré du bureau le soir m'asseoir dans
le canapé suisse et des bonbons à la
balade et quand c'est juste pas possible
maintenant il faut qu'on fasse une
activité saas a fait
de notre mode de vie l'idéal c'est vrai
c'est d'être dans notre club parce qu'on
aime nos profs on aime nos amis on aime
est entouré c'est c'est un lien social
en quelque part mais heureusement qu'on
les a des lives nous est quand même un
cas du sport de façon quotidienne encore
quelques belles séances à la maison et
si tout va bien
arnaud et sophie retrouveront leurs
salles dès le 20 janvier comme l'a
annoncé le gouvernement